good evening a local family grieving
tonight after police say a 19-year-old
man was killed in a triple shooting in
North Las Vegas this happened Tuesday
afternoon near Commerce and Centennial
Parkway police still searching for a
suspect in this case Sasha Loftus spoke
with the victim's mom tonight she joins
us now in studio with more on her
message Denise and Brian Dewayne's mom
says she's still trying to wrap her head
around what happened she says her son
was walking home from the store and he
never made it now she's asking for the
community's help to piece this all
together
he was just a life a young life taken as
it was just beginning he loved football
he loved his friends everybody loved him
Shaughnessy Dwayne Edwards mom shares
everything she loved about him we love
to smile and joke around so that's how I
want everybody to remember him police
say the 19 year old was one of three
shot Tuesday afternoon while walking
here near Commerce and Centennial
Parkway in North Las Vegas the other two
men were hurt and taken to UMC but
Dwayne didn't make it this was too soon
this was just too soon for him he had
such big plans for his life officers are
still searching for the person
responsible and Shaughnessy says her
whole family is still in shock she's
asking anyone who may know anything to
come forward so they can have some
semblance of closure I just want whoever
did this to my son to come forward or to
somebody that knew what happened to tell
me and focus on all the joy Dwayne
brought to their world he he always
laughed and joked and always made us all
laugh while remembering the man he was
and who he wanted to become I never
thought that this would happen to my son
no word on the condition of the other
two men shot if you have any information
about Dwayne's case please call North
Las Vegas Police or Crime Stoppers where
of course you can always stay Anonymous
the family has also started a GoFundMe
to help with funeral expenses we have
more information on that on our website
Denise